so i get tons of crazy calls from people  who want to tell me things about  evolution and they have no clue about  evolution but i actually want to be as  informed as possible about evolution so  i've been watching the six episode  series called evolve which is just  awesome and even as someone who's been  studying evolution for a long time and  it comes up on my show all the time  i learned a ton of stuff that i didn't  know i watched it on curiosity stream  curiosity stream is like the streaming  service for documentaries which i love  they have all the newest documentaries  documentaries about all sorts of  different things and it is so cheap so  cheap you can use my link  curiositystream.com  david and it's 15 bucks for the year  that's like a dollar 25 a month if you  like documentaries definitely do it